the ancient ruins of sebastia have long
been at the front line of a battle of
narratives in the occupied West Bank
Israelis claim them as an important part
of their history while Palestinians
living nearby say that's an excuse to
justify land grabs tourist consultant Z
daari says since October the 7th acts of
violence by Israeli settlers and
soldiers have
increased it's not safe sometimes to ask
the local Palestinian to come and to
visit the Aral site we don't know what
the Israel is still planning um after
the war because you can see there's no
one asking them what they are doing
there is no limits for the settlers uh
for the settlers in the West Bank and we
are really afraid to lose the artical
site of sabasa Sebastian's May says
while there are few tourists during the
war on Gaza Israel is also shutting off
local
access a lot of things changed after
October 7th here Israeli soldiers and
the settl increased attacks although
this has been growing since netanyahu's
far right government took power and now
there's an increase in checkpoints
around the town as preventing people
from entering the village was split as
part of the Oslo Accords signed by
Palestinian and Israeli leaders in the
United States in
1993 sebastia has been divided into two
sections under the Oslo Accords area B
under joint Israeli and Palestinian
control and over here is area C just
along this line in that's under full
Israeli military control but since
October 7th Palestinians say Israelis
have stepped up attacks against them and
have often blocked them from this site
they say for many decades before their
rights this land have continuously been
eroded 80 km South is a village of bti a
UNESCO heritage site dotted with olive
trees and Lush vegetation this area west
of bethleem is known for its steep
Terraces and aqueducts where Farmers
still use a 2,000-year-old ro Roman
irrigation system but since December
settlers have begun expanding an illegal
settlement and building a new road
blocking Farmers access to 17 acres of
land all with the support of the Israeli
military the land is filled with olive
trees which my father planted in 1986
this is a huge loss for us I spoke to
the soldiers and they blocked me from
accessing my land I told them I take
care of it daily and they order me to go
to the settlement of L to request a day
access permit during the interview
Israeli soldiers shouted at alzer's team
to stop filming and demanded to check
the
footage Farmers say as well as taking
their land illegal settlements and
expanding infrastructure could also
drain its water reserves an ancient
system they rely on for agriculture and
the very reason batier was listed as a
protected world heritage site luran Al
jazer sebastia and batier in the occup
West
Bank make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer